Castle's unexpected cancellation nearly
left fans and the creative team with
nothing but a cliffhanger what the heck
happened and why the writers of Castle
planned on getting the green light for
season 9. because of this they created a
story where Beckett and Castle are
attacked and gunned down in their home
the season was meant to end with both
castle and Beckett lying in a pool of
their own blood with their fate left up
in the air while that would have made
for a good season finale the fate of the
Cliffhanger was already revealed Beckett
would succumb to her injuries as Stana
Katic was not slated to return for
season 9. the actress had been
unceremoniously fired
can I cancel
the prize the entire premise of the
series was built around the relationship
between castle and Beckett I'm still
amazed at the depths of your strength
your heart
and your hotness it's because of her
that there are murders to solve it all
caddock's firing wasn't received
positively by longtime Castle fans as
the entire point of the show would
change with her death
the best that I've ever trained maybe
the best I've ever seen
but you weren't having any fun before he
came along
[Music]
luckily
although luckily depending
pending audiences never saw a season
without Beckett before it was revealed
That season 8 would be the final season
for Castle the series was gearing up to
go in an entirely New Direction with the
death of Stana katic's detective Beckett
the premise of the show was going to
shift season 8 had already laid
groundwork for this change as Castle
stopped working with the NYPD homicide
department in order to appease his
interest in all things murder he opens
his own Pi business where his daughter
Alexis played by Molly Quinn works with
him
turned up some got so much cooler than I
thought it would
he's also working with a new female
protagonist Haley Shipton played by
tokes alagoon day a former MI6 operative
who's moved into the security business I
hope you don't mind just giving her some
Pi lessons Haley was teaching me the art
of manipulating men she was clearly
meant to be a Beckett replacement for
the show if it continued into season 9.
according to Entertainment Weekly head
Castle been renewed it would have
revolved around Castle's Pi business as
he hunts his wife's killer it's likely
that castle would have uncovered a large
conspiracy revolving around Beckett's
death everyone in the show would be out
for blood which would allow Castle to
include all previous main characters
such as detective Javier and Detective
Ryan in the reconfigured series season 9
could have shown how Castle's search for
vengeance would take him down a dark
path but it's likely that by the end of
the season Castle would have found some
form of closure it's been suggested that
Castle stars Nathan Fillion and Stana
Katic didn't get along and that friction
is why Katic was fired now while your
inspiration might strike you sooner than
you think
an inside source spilled to Hello
magazine just how bad the cast mate's
relationship was the actors wouldn't
speak to each other outside of filming
and Katic could often be found in tears
in her dressing room according to The
Insider the crew encouraged the co-stars
to go to therapy to resolve their
intense dislike of one another U.S
weekly also reported the onset tension
another Insider claimed that Fillion was
horrible to his co-star while kadik just
wanted to get her job done without
complications
have been easy between you and me
while neither catac nor Fillion has ever
commented on these rumors the fact that
they haven't refuted the reports speaks
volumes especially in light of caddock's
surprise firing from the series Katic
was reportedly blindsided by Castle's
decision to terminate her contract at
the time however the actors remained
professional and didn't comment on her
relationship with co-star Nathan Fillion
or the show's sudden ending after some
time had passed katik shared with News
Corp that she was proud of her work on
the show and how special her character
Beckett was and that she was hurt and
confused by the way it all ended she
told the daily mail it would be a
disservice to the work that I did which
I feel partly contributed to the success
of the show if I looked back on it and
was anything but grateful for the
awesome run katik shared with
Entertainment Weekly that she found her
ending with the series harsh and that
she was still unclear as to what
happened between her and the network
however she chose to look back fondly on
her experience and on the people that
she met while working on the set just
tell us Dana what was the drama between
you and Nathan Fillion spill the tea
Alexi Howley says they always had a
contingency plan just in case the show
didn't get renewed while season 8 of
Castle was airing the network had yet to
announce there would be a season nine in
fact the cast and crew were not made
aware of the Network's decision to pull
the plug until close to the season 8
finale how Lee told Entertainment Weekly
if we hear that we're not coming back we
have shot something that we can put at
the end of the episode as a way to put a
button on everything it wasn't something
the crew wanted to do they were hopeful
Castle would be renewed which would
allow the series to tackle the
character's pursuit of Vengeance over
Beckett's death according to how late
they shot a final time Jump scene to
appease fans as they didn't want to
leave them with questions but co-show
Runner Terence Paul winter shared with
Entertainment Weekly that his Hope was
that it would never see the light of day
sadly it did the clip jumped seven years
in the future and features voice-overs
from Castle and Beckett the two are very
much alive thriving and still in love
they even have a house full of kids
proving that they still make a great
team at the end of season 6 Castle's
original showrunner Andrew Marlow
stepped down we have a great lead
producer Andrew Marlow who loves women
and so I think he loved letting her
shine as a woman in the end Marla went
out with a bang the season six finale
showed Castle being kidnapped on his
wedding day it was a punch to the gut
audiences thought they were finally
getting a happy ending only to have the
dream snatched away season 7 was the
beginning of the end for Beckett and
Castle's relationship as they were
constantly tested and pulled apart
almost as though the writers were no
longer planning to have them end up
together which well they weren't the
writers planned to kill Beckett off
before leaving Castle Marlow described
the series as a love story wrapped in a
procedural however season 7 and 8 feared
drastically from that concept the show
began to focus more on the characters of
Castle and how he flourished without
Beckett will they won't they
relationships are Staples in television
think the Vampire Diaries Scandal or
even friends audiences yearn for these
couples to wake up and get together from
the first moment of Castle it was clear
that Richard Castle was into Detective
Kate Beckett then guy is crazy about you
and despite your little act you're crazy
about him
whether she was interested in him
remained to be seen while it was obvious
that the two would be the end game their
romance wasn't necessary while castle
and Beckett were the glue holding the
series together their relationship
didn't need to turn into bones and Booth
from another similar cop drama bones
they could have followed the Mulder and
Scully model instead the two didn't need
to become a couple for the show to work
especially since they're separated by
other romantic partners by the fear of
admitting their feelings or by jobs in
different cities Beckett and Castle
hardly ever share scenes in season 8 as
Beckett's off taking part in a secret
mission and don't even get us started on
that time castle straight up disappeared
on their wedding day
[Music]
because of all this drama the couple's
happy ending feels rushed audiences
rarely saw them happy together over
eight seasons so it's hard to believe
that seven years later things are
picture perfect maybe the writers had
the right idea when they planned to kill
Beckett off the seven year time Jump
tacked on at the end of season 8 meant
to make fans happy after everything
Beckett and Castle go through the show
does a 180 and lets them live out their
lives together happily ever after
every writer needs inspiration
and I found mine
this was the original concept for
Castle's first showrunner Andrew Marlow
Marlow stepped down after season one
through six he had some standout
episodes during his time but it's season
6 episode 5 that shines when considering
the series end the episode is titled
time will tell and plays into one of
Castle's Fantastical ideas surrounding a
case he and Beckett encounter Simon
Doyle who claims he's a time traveler
sent back to stop a terrible event from
unfolding I'm a temporal Anthropologist
what we do is we travel back in time and
we study culturally significant errors
naturally Castle is all in when Beckett
has no time to engage with Doyle's
apparent delusions by the end of the
episode Doyle shares with castle that he
and Beckett are married in the future
with three kids real charmer that one
can't believe you marry her
Beckett is a senator and Castle is now
an author of serious literature while
this is a fun way to end the episode the
time jump in the series finale seemingly
confirms Doyle's prediction at least on
the kit front as Beckett is seen chasing
around three kids in her home with
Castle poor ratings are usually the
biggest driver for giving a show the ax
if a series isn't bringing in enough
viewers it's not doing its job and
networks use that as an excuse to cut
ties with a series while this can
sometimes happen too soon as with
firefly Castle is lucky enough to have
run for eight successful Seasons even if
some were praised more highly than
others according to CBR the lower
ratings from Castle season 8 heavily
contributed to the series being canceled
in fact viewership had been declining
over the previous few seasons it seems
as though season 8 was the final straw
for the network as they no longer had
faith that the show would bring in the
big numbers that it used to I thought
that you would just take you back in
spite of what you put me through
season 8 of Castle was averaging under
10 million viewers per episode and if
that sounds like a lot the highest
viewership for the network at the same
time was over 13 million season 8 saw
the show's lowest ever numbers which had
been dropping significantly since the
new showrunners took over this could be
a direct result of the show moving away
from the castle Beckett romance and more
into a castle-centric story it
are due to the decline in viewership
Castle was slated for major budget cuts
if season 9 were to move forward
according to CBR the only way another
season of Castle would have been
greenlit was if the show were able to
significantly reduce the amount of money
it was spending on production
a studio goes and casts the braless coid
and blood soaked t-shirt from knife 2.
this may have contributed to Stana
katic's dismissal from the show as both
Katic and co-star Tamela Jones who
played Dr Laney Parish were asked not to
return for season 9. according to Cinema
Blend in 2016 Katic was revealed to be
one of the highest paid actresses on
television this would have been right
around the time season 8 of Castle was
filming caddock's negotiated salary
landed her at approximately 12 million
dollars per season based on the one-year
contract she signed after filming
wrapped on season seven with budget cuts
looming and plans on moving the story
away from Castle and Beckett's romance
cutting out a 12 million dollar plus
salary is one sure way to do it
unfortunately for the crew this wasn't
enough and Castle was still canceled
luckily Beckett and Castle got the
ending they deserved which happens to be
the one that original showrunner Andrew
Marlow always envisioned
[Music]